who tried it was a Martel degree to
Nanjing laughing suffering what the
Hoffmans mystery how I shall value
by any high level pizza papa
okay
assalamu alaikum warahmatullah better
care to the body for you that nobody
hurry okay sir ah male come bubbling
sisters what we did is we did a reaction
with your today with was enough
inshallah and I think okay just keep it
real yeah okay so now this lady walks in
marshmallows for you you neither waiting
you can nother one if you wait or you
can eat it now
you get it you so she gave him a
marginal hospital said you can wait and
I know you another one or you can eat
another can eat it after how long okay
she's good okay yeah yeah so so far the
experiment is that is the marshmallow
says if you wait till I come back I'll
give you another one yes k if you eat it
and you know let's have it
like me one thing
everything off the tape from the Pope
she's great look at all your breaking is
making you think it of a breakaway
obvious north of notice a lot agenda
really looking looking looking it or
even a previous criminal innovation Oh
technical degree not talk
benefit it's like finally appointed our
office were the few dedicated canoes
were forgiven if you throw in a broken
gt80 no foreign entities it is will give
it like it I am now of the marshmallow
meringue
Oh
[Music]
Canada conditioners we do it so if you
don't need any favors or businesses a
favor
okay
you want
already and it is yum that they thought
was the salon was okay banana but what
would a young days book okay
the plane is now good it was funny yeah
but what comes to mind now they did is
ex women for a reason yeah yeah okay
what comes to your mind first me I
noticed something about coming to my my
which we could benefit from this year
yeah but the point much my don't say but
don't touch it yeah this isn't a
weakness here is gonna take over
well you're white okay what color is a
loss of hollow a lot of it what comes to
your mind what comes in when this
extreme like can you relate it to
something is it right from the start
yeah is what I was thinking about as
well if you and ain't no will do you
more Kentucky ah good good actually you
didn't give us ready and you didn't
think so what you think you okay no it's
similarly similar in my head I was just
oh yeah it's obviously obscene if the
road is greater but obviously it just
reminds me because you know what I was
concentrate on is their reactions the
fact that look imagine exactly look what
human being really for sure okay the
fact that they had a marshmallow or
something as a kid that's what they love
it they don't have anything like nothing
else again so the fact that one was i
smelling it one was just touching it one
was looking away and feeling it for and
one one was banging his head on it so
the thing is these things remind me as
human beings where we're going to test
one hard
how do i do with it what do I do it's I
put myself in that situation they're
doing that with a sweet but without this
temptation to be on jealousy so not how
do I do with it gee I'm trying to say
and it reminds me of the heavy load
force of cilantro-lime second angel
Gabriel there I was front Allah makes
Jenna and says go to Jannah go and look
at John here and it goes in as a package
in and says you know Allah
I don't think I don't think nobody would
miss this place up they would want to go
to this place
okay good go to the Hellfire angel gable
goes to the Hellfire and he says Allah I
don't know I don't think there's anyone
that would want to enter this place then
allah sends them back to Jenna I said
Kotick a general now so when it goes and
looks at Jenna who sees this tribulation
and tears etc and said Allah I don't
think any more we clear basically Assad
go back Phil is going look at the
Hellfire so he goes and looks like the
Hellfire and he sees a full of desires
and things and is like you know what I
think people just kind of everyone into
this place yeah yeah so to me it just
makes me feel like in life like I said
before is the test and tribulation that
we go through and we do within this away
just the way these kids they would look
if you
have the own types of marshmallow I'm
going to give you another one you get it
so that's real is with us it's just that
basically if we abstain from the sins in
this life desires etc that we would
enjoy life as I said what was it abstain
rain from behind me exactly much more
lazy oh yeah you guys show any but I
just really reminding of that kita
and the way they were just dealing with
they're not looking and distracting
their self for me it is remind me of
that you do you sniff your temptation
that's everybody yes yes we get but made
our marshmallows in general ensure like
this probably me oh you know you know
just a mere household the other day yet
I had a cake yeah and it was this red
velvet cake are probably take you to one
place flakes all around it
chocolate-covered strawberries on top I
mean federal Russia okay that's very
bitter well the case when we're gonna be
able case nobody eating this thing yeah
they raised more anyone asked me like
quiet because I thought if something
this beautiful and amazing you can have
it in this dunya exactly what's waiting
for you examine this is sick point I
want to make you know why yeah I'm sorry
about excited there for a second Hodgins
realize you don't know you're on the
simulator using no that's a really valid
point you know why because if you think
about it anything that we have imagine
you have little to you yeah the food
that you eat yeah okay obviously social
relations with your wife
yeah whenever it may be liberal whatever
Haram relations years I think everything
in love you know when you go to that
place it like is that was that can
ringing man what did we leave is that
alone running with a different [ __ ]
of elevator our relations with this you
know illogical you know we need
workspaces out cuz if that came to
Pakistan and it showed me have a
beautiful place and all that beautiful
yes all these little things I think they
likely would thesis or was awaiting yeah
that will taste that group is that
progress that chocolate tastes like this
year imagine in general yeah imagine if
that place is a beautiful how's it going
to look in gender and imagine only think
whatever it may be to me it's just like
little taster like you said you're not
Socrates I've imagined under so
obviously keeps us going and looking
forward to it
any last words
describe now and another thing that kids
from into a little girl yeah we can also
derive that okay
you are going to fall into sin yeah
you're going to fall into desires so
would you do say lose hope and say look
I'm finished or do you get up and try
again
exactly so that's that's that's
something that we can benefit from as
well this is probably the best videos
you'll expand on it yeah well that's not
justice Kaiser anybody's actually I like
that so much I was in that cover song
but okay would you create a little bit
what do you mean I mean I liked the
different reactions so he had one yet
even while she was being told ya she
didn't hear she entered exactly then
there were the ones that were tempted by
it yeah
and they even smelled a they licked a a
then that's all not here here I mean
this is a little bit and then there was
the one who fully just nobody's lazy day
yeah yeah yeah yeah we had by the way
we're not remain marshmallows the
females what you talking temptations
whatever it may be it's a lollipop yeah
the wrap over here if we have a really
poke the slides out that please no user
that's ingenious in any other words love
words so guys we see that the dead shut
up Musa okay so guys hope you guys are
benefited I'll be driving watches this
show if there's anything you want us to
react to meet rather Musa is Robin let
us know comment section below
in shava and bubbles noona she's coming
out check it out I'm a boy doing charity
work all day every day but you know like
I've applied observation to me since
they been on ITV I feel extra school
students it was channel years that's how
much especially we are now you are they
own
remember when you never used to answer
my calls Wendy I would answer your calls
every day I know you from day one I knew
that spot I mean you go to my friend
request on Instagram anything goodbye if
you go on BBC as well then I might do
that some of them well it's funny you
say that
okay can't say too much keep an eye from
aleikum assalam aleikum
[Laughter]
shoo-shoo shoo-shoo shoo-shoo hey give
me one I'm Chucky subscribe shoot shoot
shoot